hey folks Chris waters here on the
gamespot stage live at e3 2014 where
there are just a ton of beautiful
visually diverse games on display but
none of them look quite like morisaki
baby and this one's a treat for you so
please enjoy the demo that's about to
happen here Chris Jones joining me on
stage from X dev and Sony Europe Chris
welcome hi thanks excited to have you
guys here excited to check out Murasaki
baby which is playable now for folks in
America for the first time yeah the
first time in America well in in who are
here at the events and lining up a
second hour yeah yeah but we've got the
demo here we're gonna check it out on
vetoes right you guys announced at
Gamescom last year yeah okay / yeah yeah
and I made quite a splash how has it
been in the months since sort of as
people have an appetite for for more
Murasaki baby it's just been a real
pleasure this game is just been a labor
of love with my development team over
sonico over in milan and they're just
they're just great good bunch of guys to
work with just so just so inspiring and
so so we're just brilliant everything
they do basically be executing and right
from the beginning you see like this is
not sure you know the control scheme
here is really interesting it's a really
cool use of the touchscreen you're
holding her hand yeah exactly and that
is exactly the key point so the whole
idea of the game is to build up an
emotional bond with the player and the
baby so that the player eventually
starts to care for baby and so the
backstory is basically that baby's
looking for a mommy she's having this
bad dream and she's not actually woken
up she thinks she has what she doesn't
and she's had to be the lead web through
this world of nightmares and and you
have to basically help protect baby
through this journey so all the way
those challenges and things like that
you have to kind of help baby through
each situation and for example you know
babies afraid of the dark so you have to
lie all the path for sook moving this
light bubble on clearing out the dark
revealing a figure with its own balloon
which he had to quickly chase away yeah
so that was sensible boy he's a
character on the store chain again
tentacle boy tentacle boy yeah so this
is a little boy with a massive tentacle
knows it's actually a mask bull you know
and what it is basically each character
level as like a tragic state as part of
their dream and they have like emotions
of their own which you kind of adopt so
when you pop this balloon you've
actually gained this mood which is fear
so babies motion and everything changes
so sku she's scared you'd such the back
screen like that and it scares
everything in the foreground and you use
that to solve puzzles in the game so for
example tentacle boy doesn't Manya
following him so he's like holding this
bridge up it's at the back that scares
him and there you go is tactical boys
fear is a small girl with a toothy mouth
above her eyeballs I mean it scares me
yeah how skin to say that seems like a
pretty Universal one yeah I mean it why
a mouth is on the top of the head I'm
not quite sure but you know let's go
with it well no I mean it's it just it
all fits in with this very eerie kind of
almost Tim burton-esque aesthetic the
guys have gone so the guy the artist is
a parade is a guy who actually draws
everything by hand with a pyro and then
we scan the artwork into the computer
and then we just touch it up in like you
know we cauterize it in things it's
amazing how he actually works he just
doesn't make a mistake he just he's a
freak but he's cool so at this point in
the game you can see that light with the
Stingers are kind of trying to get your
balloon the balloon is the most
important bit obviously it being purple
purple baby so it's Murasaki baby
Murasaki's japanese for purple um so
just during this section that the baby
kind of learns as she goes so she's not
just a like a character on the screen
she's sort of waiting for the players
input to give her guidance so you kind
of leader over these holes and say okay
you can go over these holes and she
becomes automatically I'm cool with
these holes and then she kind of moves
on herself and she learns and eventually
like a little kid you have to kind of
say no don't do this that's not safe now
it's all about you got the tentacle
there so you're sort of teaching her how
to progress exactly it's all about
balancing what'swhat's watch but she'll
be scared of and watch you shouldn't be
scared of and what's acceptable and
what's safe and what's not and it's up
to the players guidance really and
that's a really interesting sort of
design approach right you're not you're
not playing as baby you know you know
hug audience she's got her own
personality her own thing she's going to
and you're this like you know in in
every game you you are a guiding force
yeah a lot of the times you're just
directly guiding this is an indirect
control scheme yeah exactly i mean
that's one of the things that makes it
good for the video i mean it just it's
just perfectly so simple just to touch
the screen and and get that emotional
feedback of holding wittle baby's hand
and it's like this this girl is fragile
and she's she's someone you want a
careful and that's really important to
us and as the game goes on she grows in
so she starts as a really timid girl
that's scared of everything and at the
end of the game she's a full-grown my
infant who's not scared of any who has
grown up yeah it's ali and the game
becomes more about protecting her rather
than guy dinner which is kind of really
important protecting her from the
sinister ashley safety pins winget
safety pins no thank you i dunno like my
eyeballs are feeling really weird about
that right now so you're not just using
the front touch screen though here it
looks like there's no yes a touchscreen
Excel me so that so everything in the
background is done through the back
torch which feels really natural you
basically change the moods of the game
by you change into the windmill mood for
example all the hell mood and then you
just tap on the back to activate is 20
and that just helps you progress through
the game levels so you saw there for a
second you know the stinkers were coming
down and use the windmill and they got
blown away by the wind so the this
section is kind of like an interlude
where we're trying to give it a little
bit of backstory about the character so
I call him tentacle boy because I know
he's a boy you know I've been working on
the game for 18 months now you got the
inside track yeah exactly no no I
everyone's going to know this so so we
have to sort of give them the backstory
and say no this little boys actually
just trapped in this tragic state and
yet it's not your job to help him out
really and so we kind of paint this
little picture and it's really good the
other characters in the game a really
clever like we have a guy called bunny
boy there's basically a disco kid
there's been eaten by a bunny rabbit
just kill kid been eaten by a bunny rare
oh yeah totally and then there's another
girl called perm girl who's obsessed
with a hair and eventually a hair
becomes like her overriding false and
you have to kind of save her from
herself or a hair should I say and this
kind of night is so twisted but it's
kind of cool and I think that you know
with a game like this that is so
creative visually and you know
artistically its discovery is such a
huge part
you know exactly of the game and you
know it's not like you know you're
you're branching out on these whatever
paths in exploring vast environments but
each but along this path that you're
going everything is kind of unexpected
that you come across yeah exactly yeah i
mean what we've kind of one is we want
people to sort of the aim is to get
everyone to play the game all the way to
to the end because we feel it's kind of
important to get the punch line at the
end I won't ruin it obviously but we
feel that it is going would be fired
immediately oh god yeah oh no it
wouldn't be that be that did a dev team
I'd be worried about to be honest they
would kill me so one of the things about
the moods is really important is that we
want to interlace them so that you use
one and then use the combination or the
ones so we've just made the situation
rain there and then raise the boat oh
yeah and then we use a set of the wind
to get the sailboat across the road now
sorry across the river later on in the
game we then subvert that and we take
away a mood and then put you in the same
situation and you've got a different
mood and got to solve the same puzzle
with a different mood sort of got it all
right well I've done it this way exactly
oh I think I know how to do this i'ma
clever clogs and it's like well maybe
not interesting yeah yeah it's you know
when you have a puzzle game there's a
couple different ways to do it you know
you sort of introduce stuff McKen like
gradually and then it grows and building
gets more and more complex yeah but I
guess you know and also where if you
take certain things away too then you're
creating forcing the player to use tools
in different ways yeah and that's
important because what we want to do is
give alternate ways to sell the same
puzzle and they're going to be like the
really outside the box thinkers and
we've been watching a lot of people play
a three and they are kind of watching it
and they're going and they've solved it
in a way that I have not seen people
solve a puzzle and it's kind of
interesting to see that and it's like
it's really rewarding to watch people do
something when you go this guy's got it
and it gets the other way of doing it as
well and it it's really exciting to
watch that so one of the things you see
there is the multi touch functionality
on the video we we use the multi-touch
quite a lot so the balloon is like the
precious thing that you've gotta protect
ya and balloons are susceptible to
spikes and are susceptible to heat and
the susceptible to being frozen and and
so the very vulnerable thing merged
birds exactly yeah yeah there's no
birds in the game maybe we should put it
well I mean flying safety pin yeah yeah
yeahs kind of counts yeah of course yeah
they're the kind of the musky oh so when
it rains outcome the outcome the
mosquitoes and that's that's also really
cool i like the this sort of burnt
matches fit for like it that looks like
a burnt match the flames there yeah yeah
yeah exactly so 10 schoolboy he's kind
of setting these traps for you because
he doesn't want you to follow him and
doesn't want to go to chase him so
you're basically just terrifying
tentacle boy that's all time he's still
totally frightened exactly it's just
kind of shy he doesn't want to be
bothered you know when you're kind of
just chasing through the level and in
slight can you leave me alone so there
he goes again you know he's setting fire
to these things and sort of say no don't
go this way yeah so you can solve these
puzzles like by putting the rain down
and then you can just float the balloon
above and now I'll expand the balloon
and actually make it bigger there's kind
of different ways of doing these same
puzzle freely which is really great now
you and I are being inundated by the
noises of e3 well I'm not know a sport
yeah so you work with but the audio of
morisaki baby you know with a game this
stylish in this moody I imagine it's a
huge part absolutely yeah vile I mean
the audio is so important to the game we
have I'm blessed with two composers so
we have a guy called Johnny Richard II
use the over sonicos composer and
co-founder and he's made these amazing
sound scapes and he did these the theme
tune to the actual release trailer and
is it's just so important to the game to
get the emotional message across and
then we have a carry omocha-san who is a
really famous guy who did the Silent
Hill component music and all that kind
of stuff and he's done a special track
for Massimo he's a personal friend so
he's done the title track for the game
and its really special and it's gonna be
over the end of the end credits of the
game so that's another reason why we
want everyone to play the game of
finished it this is does strike me as
one of those games that you know it it
builds and builds to that moment at the
end they were talking about and then you
know you stick around for like it's just
it's sort of this complete artistic work
in a way that is it's just so satisfying
exactly an experience at its entire it's
been it's almost like a bespoke
development it is
like everyone's everything that's gone
in has gone in and it's used once it's
not like we're in some repeat gameplay
it's everything's really crafted and
very cleverly put together and that's
one of the things that over sonico
xsellize is just doing everything with a
fine touch of polish and finesse so
there we go at the end of the chapter
basically reveal that but sensical boy
is actually a boy and he becomes your
friend and his mouth is over his
eyeballs to of course it makes so much
sense yeah and he leads you on to the
next chapter a level basically and
you'll see tentacle boy again in the way
or end of the game but I won't ruin that
and I'd it and on you go and you're
gonna try and find mommy going on to
find mommy and maybe a disco boy I love
the the two long sleeve the you know the
hand like retracted so many little
touches here ah says more sake baby
coming soon at the end of that demo yes
Suh so it's coming to playstation vita s
ASN exclusively September 2014 September
yeah alright that's that's pretty soon
yeah it is pretty soon it's coming
sometime yeah you guys got a little bit
of ways to go before you can uh before
that time yeah yeah yeah we're fine
we've got plenty of time so I think we
could nothing we good excellent Chris
morisaki baby September to PS Vita and
on PSN did he say or just just as PS MV
PlayStation Vita yeah said Evita yeah
cuz of course that touch screen so
integral to the game exactly yep you
know I trying to remember the last game
that I like held somebody's hand in its
and there are some but I I can't quite
remember which they are i'm sure the
game swatch at will light up with hand
holding examples in video games i say
that i was Chris if you say I co anyway
got it there it is yet Chris thank you
so much man for coming on but if I
Murasaki baby beautiful game looking
forward to that voice in September